to west africa now which is literally
being washed away ghana's coastline is
being eroded by the ocean this is a
natural process but it's being made
worse by human activity climate change
and more severe weather patterns for
communities on the coast the lack of sea
defenses are the increasing wind and
wave activity meaning many ghanaians
live precariously close to an
unpredictable neighbor the gulf of
guinea gw reporter isaac lege visited
one part of ghana's volta region that
may soon be gone
bare bones of the palm trees on the
shoreline show the last remnants of a
village under siege from the sea
fuverme in ghana's water region could
soon disappear forever
last november the ocean waves
crashed into this community
washing away homes and livelihoods
the floods displaced hundreds of people
many families are still homeless
knowledge dawanu was forced to flee by
the rising water
he's back in the house where he grew up
the place that was his home for decades
the one was driven from his four walls
by the waves that swept through the
village
still traumatized
he is pleading with the government for
help
now this disaster
is happening all the places but the most
difficult one is
the performer here because we share the
boundary with the river voter and so
forth and so on so they have to protect
us if not
we will die
the searching waters mean the people of
fuverme have given up any hope of
rebuilding
for hundreds of families their only
shelter is makeshift structures built of
palm fronds
they can't afford more expensive
materials and fear what little they have
could end up washed away by the ocean
when the next floods come
and come they will as they have for
decades now
fuverme used to be a prosperous fishing
village but now the sea is just a few
meters away from its ruins
as sea levels have risen the lack of
coastal defenses has let the waves take
the land
jewel deck is an environmentalist and
researcher into coastal erosion
he says climate change has contributed
significantly to the rising waters along
ghana's shoreline
destructive waves have become more
frequent
he fears that they are also a threat for
communities behind the coastline
the space between the lagoon and the sea
is being narrowed the sea is about to
enter the last tidal wave that okay
the sea went into the lagoon the waves
went through town the remaining town and
went into the lagoon a sign that in few
years to come the sea may take over
those places so there is a great danger
ahead
defenses like these have been built to
protect some communities
but the government says there is not
enough money to build sea walls to
protect everyone
rafal abanavo is the local
representative for this district he's
inspecting the damage done to fuvemei
the one who tells him he feels let down
by the government
agbanovo admits more needs to be done to
protect the community
and the environment
it's not a matter of even protecting the
people per se but look at the natural
environment
the vegetation water bodies have been
destroyed by the sea because we have a
lagoon back of this community you have
mangrove back of this community coconut
trees you lost as many as seven thousand
there is only the shell left standing of
knowledge there were no childhood home
he and thousands like him will have to
find new ones
with no certainty that they want to lose
them again to the waves consuming
ghana's coastline
for more on this i'm now joined by
professor christie pienenado he's the
director institute for environment and
sanitation studies university of ghana
hello and welcome to the program
professor you've researched the
development of ghana's coasts from
historic records since the late 19th
century what developments did you
discover over the years
thank you very much and hello to your
cherished listeners and viewers
what we identified is that erosion is
not new it's something that has been
there for a long time
but then the challenge is that
development has grown so close
to the shoreline and therefore
interacting with the natural dynamics of
the system
and because of the the interaction
between human development and the
natural dynamics of the shoreline that
is what is creating the problems and
hence the enhanced impact of erosion
undeveloped communities and then
people around
how how bad has it gotten
it's really
it has become extremely bad in the sense
that
we have lots of people now being
affected we have
several areas of the coastal communities
also being affected especially the
vulnerable areas
and
it's really affecting the livelihoods of
people who live within the coastal
communities
and
by extension also affecting
the the economy because once the
livelihood of people are affected then
the economy is also affected so
there are all sorts of factors at play
here but what is the main driving force
behind coastal erosion
several factors as you rightly said can
be attributed to coastal erosion they
are natural factors and then also human
induced
factors the natural factors there isn't
much you can do about it
but the human induced factors are what
we can
do something about it
what we observed is that in recent times
the intensity and severity has increased
as a result of storm such
being driven by climate change
and then we also have
increasing um
activities with regards to uh intensive
wave but wave wave wave activities and
then we also identified the increasing
sea level
rise which has also resulted in some of
these
activities so these are some of the
natural factors driven by climate change
where somebody can also say that climate
change is human induced
well
it's true but these are some of the
natural factors that are driving erosion
along our coast in terms of human
activities we can talk about sand
winning
and although there is a ban on some
winning but it is not being enforced so
people indiscriminately
uh wind sand on the beaches we also have
destruction of coastal vegetation and
these coastal vegetation are very vital
in naturally fighting erosion so these
are some of the factors that i can
easily talk about and we can also talk
about sedimentation once you
have influenced the sediment dynamics
the sediments the the the sand that are
along the shoreline once you influence
the segment dynamics then you are
bound to have some of these activities
occurring so clearly something should be
done about it we've had criticism of the
government's coastal management plan can
i help at all or what's the way forward
yes
definitely something needs to be done
about it but the way we go about it is
critical
presently the government is using hard
engineering approach
where they try to
manage erosion by what i call fighting
erosion
so they put you know
harsh structures like
sea walls and then groins
and the whole idea is to intercept
sediment and help to build beaches in
areas where they are eroded but then as
you trap sediment to build beaches you
deprive the downdraft side of sediment
so it's like robbing peter to pay paul
in trying to solve a problem here you
create a bigger problem down downstream
so the method that the government has
been using over the years are not
sustainable so we need to rethink as a
country how we can effectively manage
erosion but not fight erosion
okay professor chrysia pneunado from the
university of ghana thank you very much
for the insights
it's a pleasure thank you
you